we need to understand just two simple
angles in a circle first an angle like
this with its vertex at the center of
the circle is called a central angle
it's simple they are just two radii
forming an angle and the second time
it's an angle which has its vertex at
the circumference of the circle such
angles are called inscribed angles
vertex at the center central angle and
vertex on the circumference inscribed
angle these two angles are related in a
special way let's draw an inscribed
angle the vertex is on the circumference
if you notice this angle subtends an arc
here let's call it arc ACB how do we
draw the central angle of the same arc
yes like this vertex at the center this
is the central angle and this is the
inscribed angle now we come to the most
vital point of this session the
inscribed angle is exactly half of the
central angle that subtends the same arc
if this will be 40 degrees then this
will measure 80 degrees conversely if
this is 70 then this will be 35 degrees
let's look at a special case of this
look at this figure and guess the
inscribed and the central angles
assuming PQ is a line segment passing
through the centre ok angle P R Q is the
inscribed angle as its vertex lies on
the circumference and the arc it
subtends is arc PS q the question we
should ask ourselves is what is the
central angle of arc PS q its angle p
oq' doesn't quite look like an angle as
it is a straight line but it definitely
is it's this hang
the inscribed angle is half of the
central angle do we know angle p oq' of
course if it is a straight angle it will
measure 180 degrees angle PR q will
measure half times 180 degrees which
will be 90 degrees it is a right angle p
q is the diameter and two semicircles
are formed here's a typical kind of
problem that you might see in your exams
we are given the measure of angle ADB is
30 degrees the area of the circle is
given as 9 PI and we are asked to find
the length of Arc AC B so we have been
asked to find this curved length all we
have is the area of the circle and the
measure of this angle what do we need to
find the length of an arc yes
the first thing required is its central
angle we can draw two radii like this
and call its central angle theta the
length of Arc ACB will be theta over 360
degrees times the circumference which is
2 PI R out of the 2 unknowns on the
right we have none but can we find them
probably theta is the central angle of
arc AC B which is the arc subtended by
this inscribed angle and we learned that
the inscribed angle is exactly half of
the central angle that subtends the same
arc 30 being half of theta implies that
theta will be twice that of 30 it will
be 2 times 30 degrees which equals 60
degrees we have found one unknown how do
we find the radius don't forget we have
also been given the area the area is 95
and the area of a circle is PI R squared
solving this gives us the value of R as
3 centimeters substituting these values
here we get
left oh a CB as pi centimeters
you